el salvador has been stealing the
spotlight in south and central america
every single person is paying attention
to what is president buchelli and that
country doing but other countries in
south and central america are not going
to be left behind when they announced
being el salvador that bitcoin was going
to become legal tender in the country
all of a sudden there was plenty of
politicians across the region that
started to put laser eyes on twitter
they started to talk about bitcoin they
started to talk about potential
legislation we now are seeing some of
that come to fruition and so we've got
brazil
has new legislation that has been
proposed the special committee of the
chamber of deputies has looked at this
new bill and said
we should consider making bitcoin legal
tender within the country el salvador is
awesome we love the fact that the
country of six and a half million
citizens has decided to go ahead and
make it legal tender they not only
promised it but they executed on it but
it is a different ball game if a country
like brazil it's much bigger it's a
larger economy it has a different kind
of mental place in the minds of people
across the world so if brazil was to do
this it would be an absolute game
changer it would kind of be the 201
level of this game now when we go ahead
and we actually look at it what we can
see is we've got this tweet from felipe
yevis cardinal i probably pronounced it
wrong i apologize but when asked what
exactly does this mean felipe said they
want to designate bitcoin as a payment
method that would be the same thing as
airline mile point systems and other
types of payment methods so that it may
be supervised by the brazilian central
bank transactions will be covered by
consumer protection laws it may clear up
some legal quandaries but that's it so
we don't know exactly how this is going
to play out is it legal tender is it
considered simply a payments method
there are still a lot to be figured out
but in the country of brazil
if we see legislative movement in a
positive light that brings bitcoin into
the mainstream it is likely to serve as
a massive tailwind and a big boom we
then have two separate quotes from ario
rabirio again probably saying it
incorrectly i apologize uh that says
quote a text that recognizes this asset
which allows the transaction of this
asset in our country and which will be
regulated by a government agency because
we will work with the central bank and
the cvm depending on how this asset will
be recognized asset such as real estate
value or currency for daily use so
basically this text is looking to
understand more clearly how is bitcoin
going to be treated within the country
the second quote says we want to
separate the wheat from the shaft create
regulations so that you can trade know
where you are buying know who you are
dealing with and have this asset to buy
a house a car go to mcdonald's to buy a
hamburger it will be a currency in the
country as it happens in other countries
so one of the key pieces to bitcoin is
that it has historically served as a
global store of value people have bought
it and they've held it for a long period
of time they believe that the purchasing
power will continue to increase but as
more and more people adopt the asset the
market stops trying to reprice it as a
global store of value and it starts to
say
how much utility does this provide well
if brazil all of a sudden says this is
legal tender and we have infrastructure
being built out like the lightning
network you could clearly see a path to
bitcoin being used as an actual medium
of exchange within the country this is
not going to happen overnight it's going
to take quite a while it could take
years to play out but part of what the
work that is being done now is doing is
it's laying the foundation for that
future that we all hope for you have to
have the legislative
environment so that actually it is not
treated in a hostile manner you need to
have the infrastructure in place you
need to have the users familiar and
there also needs to be the macro
tailwinds brazil argentina el salvador
etc their citizens are not nearly as
well off as they should be some of those
countries like el salvador are
dollarized other of those countries have
super high inflation i don't know what
brazil says but i know argentina is
nearly 50 a year and so when you start
to look at the macro tailwinds in these
countries across south and central
america you start to look at the
infrastructure that's being built you
start to look at the geopolitical
competition that plays out and then you
look at the incentives of a politician
do you feel like you're an unknown
politician in your country do you have
national aspirations do you want to be
known on a global stage well you should
embrace bitcoin because when you embrace
bitcoin you immediately put bitcoiners
around the world millions and millions
and millions of bitcoins around the
world to work for you because if you
embrace bitcoin if you work to start to
push it forward the bitcoiners will make
sure that the world knows your name that
is the promise to politicians is if you
fight this you will be destroyed by the
bitcoiners online there's no other
community in the world that goes
toe-to-toe with world leaders with
company ceos or with pseudo-anonymous
people
but the abrasiveness is not necessary if
you embrace the technology if you start
to understand the superiority of the
technology the bitcoiners will get
behind you and they will help support
you we've seen this with public
companies we've seen this now with a
country we've seen this with cities
we've seen this with states and we've
seen it with private businesses we've
also seen it with athletes musicians and
business leaders if you embrace bitcoin
you get the tailwind you get the
immediate employment of millions of
people around the world that are working
to make you in a better position do we
think brazil is actually going to
approve this as legal tender
it would uh surprise me i think right
because we'd immediately going from el
salvador a country that has six and a
half million people at the 112th largest
country on a population basis in the
world to brazil which is the sixth
largest country with 212 million people
so a massive massive massive jump when
you look at it from a size and
population standpoint and quite frankly
would be a game changer right like el
salvador is a great story uh obviously
from an adoption standpoint kind of how
it's been going so far and we'll see if
that continues but it's grabbed national
headlines or uh international headlines
has done all this kind of stuff but if
you look at it and uh brazil was able to
do a similar bill where it's legal
tender in their country i think it would
change everything it's it's you know one
of the largest countries in the entire
world with 212 million people
significantly significantly bigger and
would have a much bigger impact uh than
el salvador and not only would it uh
have a much bigger impact from a
population standpoint but i'm assuming
the country would go out and buy bitcoin
themselves right so uh from a pure
dollar in price appreciation standpoint
on the demand side it would also look a
lot different than el salvador
well said brazil is obviously
a much larger market in economic
powerhouse compared to el salvador i
believe that el salvador has the
advantages of probably moving
legislation a little bit quicker than
brazil but i see i see this passing um
and i think it's also important to note
that part of the bill was talking about
regulations and fines that can be
associated with using cryptocurrencies
for illicit stuff right so money
laundering or anything like that so it
basically just brings in bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies as a whole uh into the
economy it's gonna be interesting to see
what is it the total volume of payments
processed in cryptocurrencies of q1 this
year was 40 million dollars right so
it's just it's growing over 400 percent
year over year
it i don't think this will be in place
this year i
maybe next year i read some stuff that
they have an election next year so it's
very up in the air but i see this going
into place
at some point in the future
i also think that there's a really
interesting element to uh in countries
that have the certain political
environments they're leading to some of
the adoption we also see uh this game
theory playing out where which countries
are going to adopt it uh and which
countries will bend the knee which
countries will uh stand up we saw uh
president buchelli and el salvador
basically put the middle finger up to
the imf with remains to be seen whether
a smart move or not uh you could see a
country like brazil
how much are they willing to be defiant
to the global monetary community
and how much of it do they feel like
they are reliant on that global
community for uh gdp growth and and for
making sure that their citizens are okay
lots and lots and lots of questions in
here but to see them
even talking about it remember bitcoin
literally launched january 3rd 2009.
we're talking about in a 12-year period
we now almost 13 years we now have a one
nation state that's adopted at this
legal tender they literally have
onboarded about 50
uh of their citizens we now have another
major country in the world that is
talking about doing this whether they
actually do it or not in some weird way
just them talking about it is already a
win because it begins to normalize the
fact that bitcoin could become legal
tender and over time you're gonna get
younger and younger leaders that step up
into those leadership positions and they
will end up thinking it's just the
default of course bitcoin should be
legal tender and they'll go ahead and
end up doing it yeah i i agree i think
uh it's it's true your point about kind
of who's dependent on the international
banking community right and like
what i think we saw with el salvador
yeah sure they're dependent but also
from some kind of point right like
they're smaller uh and they have the
flexibility to go out and do things like
this i think brazil would be a much
bigger step not only based on kind of
the size of their country and the
population but also like you said the
dependence on kind of the international
banking system i think it would be uh
kind of a wake-up call for a lot of
people if a country of that size went
out and adopted bitcoin as legal tender